[Música]
bueno muchas gracias a la organización
por invitarme a tardar un poquito acá
mi charla se llama tranquilísimo no es
un poco este y esto es lo empecé a
pensar yo trabajo actualmente
acompañando a gente para hacer sus tesis
o armar las o redirigirlas o comenzar
las y una de las cosas que pasa al
principio era que cuando me llamaba un
chico una chica para hacer la tesis me
decía profe tengo un problema y yo decía
flauta hacer la tesis después de 45 años
de carrera que ella estudiante que ella
te esforzaste que ya te sacrificas te es
la mejor parte porque bueno se supone
que vas a investigar lo que vos quieras
vas a hacerlo en el tiempo que quieras
en el formato que quieras
de ninguna manera es un problema
y me puse a pensar cuántas veces
problematiza más cosas o circunstancias
que realmente no son problemas y
nosotros la problemática más
las circunstancias me puse a pensar en
ese momento también de haber de cinco
cosas que me pasaran en el día y que yo
considerara problemas cuántas eran
realmente problemas digo a ver de las
cinco que estoy pensando bueno hay una
que problema porque no tengo influencia
a eso dios saque que pase habían dos que
las circunstancias que las tenía que
pasar a como de lugar y habían otras dos
más que eran estupideces absurdas
del primer nivel digamos en que
digo que nosotros o problemas o sea de
cinco cosas que me preocupan unos
problemas y las otras no lo son
esta vez a las circunstancias no son
necesariamente problemas no es que no lo
sean pero no son necesariamente
problemas
por otro lado digo bueno a ver
pongámonos a pensar en cada uno por cuál
fue la última el último problema por el
que llore pataleé me volví loco no hace
48 horas para atrás
qué problema grave habrá tenido la gente
a ver la gente que tiene menos de 30 de
25 el gran problema son los teléfonos
no se le quedó corto el cable del
teléfono por ejemplo esa solución
problema es y por eso es una
circunstancia después por ejemplo no se
va a sacar la comida del horno
microondas está fría no es un problema
es una circunstancia aprieta el botón un
poco más
son dos minutos más los problemas
circunstancias que otros problemas
graves solemos tener digamos como que
guau qué drama el auto el auto de un
gran drama para la gente que el auto no
lo lave que sí lo lave llovió o sea no
son problemas son circunstancias
entonces y bueno intentemos no
problematizar las circunstancias o sea a
ver si pasó la comida pasó algo señor
por qué abandonaste a tu hija deje la
llave de la casa de adentro y estoy
afuera o sea eso no es un problema es
una circunstancia
o sea entonces la idea que tenía yo es
que sigo teniendo con los taxistas a
quienes acompañó con los alumnos que
tengo hoy en día es no problema tenemos
una circunstancia las circunstancias va
a pasar o sea las vamos a tener que
atravesar estas y todas y intentemos no
disfrazar la de problema ese es un tema
bastante importante para nosotros
si nos ponemos a ver la definición del
problema problema problema asunto oscuro
que la la la la la la hace a ver el no
me creo más no calentó la comida no
tiene nada de oscuro o sea darle al
botón dos veces más si ya pasó o bueno
nada me quise planchar el pelo me quedo
como techo de pagoda bueno vengo con el
techo de pago que no es de un problema
hemos visto testimonios que son
realmente muy complejos y que sí que
siempre uno se pone a pensar flauta
cuántas cosas hay que no lo son
la realidad es que las circunstancias
van a pasar las vamos a tener que
atravesar digamos y lo más interesante
es poder también
[Música]
digamos intentar centrarnos en lo mejor
porque lo que te centras se expande se
intentó atravesarlo súper bien las
circunstancias y nada
subordinarla a suponer ese fastidio que
por ahí tenemos que podemos subordinar
el fastidio a un firmas grande a un algo
más interesante digamos podemos ir
atravesando todo tipo de circunstancias
lo que tenemos que hacer creo que en
principio y creo que es cada día y en
cada circunstancia problemático no
digamos es intentar serenar nos un poco
vivir con un poco más de sencillez bajar
un poco la atención de cada cosa
atravesarlo con más naturalidad esto
vivir con sencillez bajar un poco y no
demandar tanto no tener tanta ansiedad
bajar un poco no tener tanta exigencia
con el resto tampoco muchas veces los
que trabajamos en instituciones son
lugares públicos tenemos con mucha
exigencia hacia el resto empresa tiene
mucha exigencia entonces empezamos a
enredarnos en una
red simbólica compleja
y eso termina siendo problema de algo
que era más fácil de atravesar ser más
livianito de sangre como decíamos antes
insisto en que cuando uno tiene una
circunstancia puede hacer dos cosas
muchas más pero básicamente dos creo yo
que una es armar una gran bolsa como
esta la super bolsa de casey de residuos
digamos en el que está lo que no puede
dominar lo que no voy a tener manejo
digamos poner en esa bolsa de problemas
todo desde el horno microondas hasta la
pila el reloj
y llenarlas y digamos gigante de manera
tal que resulte algo casi imposible de
manejar y del cual no pueda ni siquiera
empujar las esferas para sacarla
y esta bolsa hay que tener en cuenta
mucho también se lo digo a los chicos
más chiquitos tener en cuenta que esa
bolsa está llena de lo que piensa el
resto de nosotros llena de esa idea de
no es cierta la perspectiva social sobre
nosotros que va a pensar el otro si hago
el que va a pensar el otro que va a
pensar el mundo es una de las frases que
más vidas ha jorobado porque la verdad
es que van a pensar sí y así mucha gente
los que son de la generación de más de
40 años teníamos un poquito grabado eso
de para hacer las cosas hay que hacerlas
bien sino no hay que hacerlas no intenta
hacerlas hacerlo lo mejor posible pero
intenta hacerlas digamos si no estás
neutralizando te de entrada no sabes si
te va a salir bien o no para hacer las
cosas hay que hacerlas hay que hacerla
hay haciéndolas se van viendo solas
digamos
e insisto con el tema también de los de
los más chicos en esa bolsa de los
problemas de lo que no puede influir
está también la visión del resto de la
atribución social el peso de lo como me
ven liberémonos de eso sino la bolsa es
imposible no lo podemos sacar después
esa bolsa de residuos
podemos ponerlo también en la bolsa de
nuestra influencia esa bolsa de nuestra
influencia tiene más del ser de lo que
puedo hacer del bajar un poquito la
exigencia que pueda hacer yo para
bancarme estar en el banco y que haya en
20 personas delante o 30 o 40 bloques
vaya que pueda ser bueno me llevo un
libro el hotelero lo manejo con
previsión con sencillez la previsión
también te bajan la ansiedad y la
cantidad de problemas digamos la
cantidad de problematización del tema
y esto tejer la propia red
la propia red simbólica torre simbólica
es tuya o sea la tejera este gesto con
las cebras que crees con los colores que
quiere decir no la quieres tejer no la
dejes torre simbólica va cambiando con
la edad con las circunstancias con el
tiempo con con tu trabajo con tu estudio
con tu vocación la red simbólica es
propia son son colores propios digamos
es tuya y es una locura tejer redes
simbólicas complejas que no podemos
hacer es una locura intentar meterse en
redes simbólicas ajenas que te presionan
y te sofocan eso es un gran problema que
también tienen los más jovencitos y los
más grandes también tenemos
insisto en esto crear su propia red
simbólica y deshacer las cuantas veces
sea necesario y dejarlas con los hilos
que sean necesarios y no dejarlos si no
tiene gana y si queda abierta a la red
simbólica y bueno nada pasa por ahí ya
otra cosa
volviendo al tema de las circunstancias
hay una cosa que es muy cierta y muy
real y que la podemos ver todos los días
en cada cosa que hiciéramos que la que
hagamos que entre la circunstancia y la
respuesta lo que vaya a suceder que no
lo podemos manejar y la respuesta hay un
espacio un espacio total en ese espacio
cabe nuestra manera de elegir o sea en
esa manera de elegir está la libertad
todo el tiempo
todo el tiempo y esa libertad en la que
nos pone también en esta bolsa de la
influencia del poder generar lo ya del
hacerlo son muchas las personas que
estuvieron hablando son personas que han
que han atravesado las circunstancias y
se formaron y se reconstruyeron y
reconstruyeron sus redes simbólicas las
fueron cambiando las veces que era
necesario o sea
así es creo que es una de las faltas más
interesantes para vivir el día a día
insisto con el corte de pelo con el auto
con el cable de teléfono y con todo
el dragón chino esto me lo contó un
amigo hace muchos años y me pareció
súper interesante los problemas son
convendrá gonchi no los vemos tremendos
y los devora se nos acercan nos va a
reventar en cualquier momento es algo de
un material este increíble digamos
imposible de deshacer es muy complejo y
te vas acercando no es cierto en la
fiesta de la vida esta celebración
te vas acercando al dragón chino y te
das cuenta que el dragón chino es en
realidad un monstruo de papel que está
en una fiesta en una celebración en este
caso en el año nuevo chino un monstruo
de papel
que si vos te acercas no es cierto te
das cuenta que es de papel van bailando
no es cierto con el con el dragón chino
si te acercas más ves que lo vas
llevando a unos tragos con unos palitos
de dragón que me va a devorar de entrada
no veis es un dragón de papel que va
bailando en la danza de la vida y tiene
unas personas con palitos abajo o sea
podemos ver los problemas de dos maneras
cuando lo defines problemas como el
dragón anterior que me devora o como el
dragón chino de papel que dance
alegremente y bueno lo hacemos nosotros
con él muchas gracias
[Aplausos]